well mental health professionals say
they are already seeing an increase in
patients anxious about the coronavirus
the American Psychiatric Association
estimates that nearly 30% of adults
suffer from an anxiety these an anxiety
disorder at some point in their lives
anxiety disorders differ from normal
feelings of nervousness and often
involve excessive fear or uneasiness and
these disorders are the most common form
of mental illness psychiatrist dr. su
Varma is here with how to manage your
fears about the corona virus good
morning did you expect this this is
taking you by surprise and what can
folks do to alleviate some of these
concerns yes so this level definitely I
am surprised and I understand that we
need to have emotional insight and
awareness I think that the anxiety
disorders come because we're contending
with a war on two fronts one is with the
cognitive distortions that are in our
mind and one is with the external
reality and in my practice what I'm
finding is that developing this broach
which I like to call practical
philosophy practical is what can you
actually do and the the optimism
practical optimism is about how can we
change and challenge some of these
negative distortions is that what you
call a productive way to worry exactly
so a productive worry is what can I do
so I'm finding that telling people to
pick one reliable news source whether
it's the CDC gov whether it's this show
and then limit the 11 level of
intrusions we're getting a lot of
intrusions onto our phone we don't need
to know a minute-by-minute and also I
would say is ask yourself what is
happening locally yes we want to know
what's happening in China and what's
happening in Italy but what is happening
in your local school systems that to me
that's the most important thing is terms
of the preparedness this uncertainly is
particularly troublesome isn't it for
people already struggle with anxiety
exactly and you know one thing what
we're finding is first what we were
seeing that the things that were going
off the shelves were the masks the hand
sanitizers and guess what
now it's toilet paper right why because
it gives us something to do we're
finding that you know all of these
stores are running out of supplies
because of the anxiety that we are
projecting the Kadett struck
catastrophizing the what-if thinking the
ruminations right in
dad we need to say what can I do how can
I separate emotion from fact and that's
the most important thing in dealing with
the facts here how do we talk to our
kids about this yes so kids need to be
reassured by the parents first of all
have age-appropriate conversations let
them lead see where they're at see what
their fears are a lot of times we're
getting sort of what we call stress
contagion where the parents are putting
their anxiety on the kids kids like to
be productive they like to know facts
like okay this is not hitting the
children who is this hitting who are the
most vulnerable people it's not the kids
here
it's the elderly people who are noodle
compromised or who have multiple medical
conditions were exposed to recent travel
who are going on cruise ships so letting
them know the context and yes there is a
virus you play a part in this by washing
your hands singing happy birthday two
times twenty seconds so the kids may
have the virus they're not exhibiting it
but they could be passing it along
you're not likely you're not like that
it gets sick but your school may get
shut down exactly yes and then having a
plan with them what are we going to do
just the way parents have to think about
summer during the summer when the kids
are home or are you going to have screen
time are you gonna have books are you
gonna have games who's gonna be the
caretaker how about service to community
there you go that's what my alternative
Spring Break absolutely you know people
can sometimes get through a virus with
enhanced immunity I wonder when you're
dealing with this from an anxiety point
of view getting through this could you
have kind of immunity to this sort of
event going forward is there a silver
lining in other words you know I love
that question because when I think about
the 4ms of mental health mastery is one
of them right in addition to mindfulness
and meaningful engagement and movement
but mastery is not about what you're
good at it's about what you've overcome
right and as me as a former 911 medical
director resilience is something really
important and post-traumatic growth so
what can we learn how can we come
together and how can we be stronger as a
result and some anxiety be a good thing
yes absolutely anxiety is normal and
anxiety helps motivate you it helps park
your resources and the first question
for me is anxiety is what is it what
information do I need and how can I move
forward from this so you need to
recognize the emotional aspect get help
talk to your therapist have a support
system if you need to do more FaceTime
we're not getting to have as many
in-person interactions especially if
you're sick or you're self quarantine or
self distancing but don't stop the
support system that is so important we
need help more than ever before yeah
yeah and be sympathetic to one another
don't just say calm
down it's very dismissive yeah dr. su
Varma thank you very much